we begin this morning with president
Trump's trip to Asia as he faces
mounting pressure here at home after he
arrives in Japan today the president
hopscotch is through five different
countries in Asia where he'll push for
increased pressure on North Korea meet
with China's president attend an
economic summit and go one-on-one with
Rodrigo Duterte the controversial
president of the Philippines but back in
Washington President Trump is facing
challenges questions persist about
special counsel Robert Muller's
investigation of the Trump campaign
while Congress takes up a tax reform
plan but the president has said will be
the largest in history before heading to
Japan president Trump made a stop in
Hawaii his first state his first visit
to the state since the election Jamie
yuccas is in Honolulu Jamie good morning
good morning on Twitter the President
thanked Hawaii for the beautiful welcome
the one-day stopover did include in a
whyville ceremony where both the
president and first lady received
traditional leis later the president
made his first ever trip to Pearl Harbor
but displayed the pleasantries it turns
out that the president will have looming
questions over his administration when
he leaves Hawaii today for Asia
President Trump
laid a wreath at the USS Arizona
Memorial at Pearl Harbor Friday his
visit to the shrine of America's lost
servicemembers coming after a meeting
with the leaders of the US Pacific
Command where they discussed the ongoing
threat of North Korea's nuclear program
a topic on the president's mind as he
left on his first official tour of Asia
we'll be talking about obviously North
Korea
we'll be enlisting the help of a lot of
people but the president's domestic
problems could haunt him on this trip
which starts less than a week after the
indictment of his former campaign
chairman Paul mana for an ex aide Rick
gates in a guilty plea by a former
campaign aide George papadopolis
according to court papers filed by
special counsel robert muller
Papadopoulos suggested arranging a
meeting between then candidate Trump and
Russian President Vladimir Putin a
meeting the president says was not
memorable I don't remember much about
that bathing it's a very unimportant
meeting took place a little time don't
remember much about it now it's being
reported another former Trump campaign
advisor Carter page met with Russian
government officials during a 2016 trip
to Moscow something he is denied doing
according to the new york times page
emailed a trump campaign aide about
those conversations the paper reports
that email was read aloud during pages
testimony Thursday before the House
Intelligence Committee Muller's
investigation has frustrated the
President on Friday three Republican
congressman introduced a resolution
calling for molars resignation but in an
interview with the Sinclair Broadcast
Group the president says he's confident
he will be absolved of any wrongdoing
well I hope he's treating everything
fairly and if he is I'm gonna be very
happy because when you talk about
innocent I am truly not involved in any
form of collusion with Russia believe me
the president is very likely to be asked
about Russia on this trip too as a
matter of fact on Friday a Kremlin
spokesperson would not rule out a
potential meeting between president
Trump and Vladimir Putin next week at an
economic summit in Vietnam
Anthony Jamie yuccas in Honolulu thanks